you want to embark on something it's
desirable
to figure out if success is at least one
of the possibilities
i was speaking to a
group of wall street analysts
and and my number
one recommendation number one personal
recommendation
was the dvd called slave girls beyond
infinity
i've done over 35 000
interviews in my career and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way
asks this question wanna be happy build
a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how billionaires
think
and get some success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one expect success with elon musk
and generally you want to
embark on something it's desirable to
figure out if success
is at least one of the possibilities
right exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes
um but but ideally you want to try to
bracket it and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
yeah
um and i wasn't quite sure if that was
the case
um i mean i think success on an academic
level would have been
quite likely because you can publish
some useless paper and
most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect
i'm sorry i mean that's what we have how
many phd papers are actually used
by someone ever um i mean no it's a good
point percentage-wise it's not
it's not good and um
so so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
uh you add some leaves to the tree of
knowledge
yeah okay um and that leaf is nope it's
not possible
right they go seven years a month
so that so that was one path and i was
prepared to do that but then the
internet was
the error came along and i was like okay
the internet i'm pretty sure
success is one of the possible outcomes
and it seems like i could either
do do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen
or i could participate and help build it
in some fashion you know
you know like i just couldn't stand the
idea of watching it happen
yeah yeah so that that's uh so i decided
to put things
on hold uh and start an internet company
and that was kind of a we we worked on
internet like publishing software maps
and directions yellow pages kind of
things
rule number two take risks with bill
gates
now part of the thing that drives
computer science forward is
is doing risky things having a long term
time horizon
and when microsoft was a small company
we benefited from the fact that
a t and xerox and other companies had
made
investments in research that they'd
reached out and worked
with universities on a broad basis so we
felt very lucky that as we got
to a certain level of success we could
start our own research
group and have that research group be
in partnership with top universities all
over the world
doing advanced programming programs
things that range from
the work on speech recognition all the
way up to quantum computing
we have a fairly serious program that
has a you know high risk of failure
uh which makes it fun and interesting on
quantum computing and you know even in
the best case it's probably
a decade away before that makes a
difference but that's the kind of thing
that when it works can have incredibly
high payoff rule number three
ask for help with warren buffett there's
a company here in
in washington called geico you know and
i i first got exposed to that
in 1950 i was i was 20 years
i was 19 years old it was 51 i'm sorry i
was 20 years old and
i came down here and i came down on a
saturday
because i learned that my professor who
i worshipped at columbia named ben
graham was the chairman
i got down here and the door was locked
when i went to the building because it
was saturday and i pounded on the door
and some janitor let me in and
a marvelous fellow named laura davidson
spent four hours with me teaching me all
about insurance and he
he helped me so much in life but you're
going to get you're going to get help by
some wonderful people in life it's it's
a great thing to
to remember later on when you're to be
my age that you know all the help you've
received from different people because
uh nobody does it alone obama got in
trouble when he
said that in the campaign that you know
nobody does it by themselves nobody does
do it by themselves
we all sit in the shade of trees that
were planted by others so
it's obligatory i think to plant a few
trees ourselves if we've had good luck
uh
it's it's been a great ride but it's not
over
rule number four have an adversary with
grant cardone
when you talk about women that's not
what i think about all right
tell me i don't think about the jet
uh i mean i think about my kids my wife
all the time i love my kids
like like oh my god man right
the fact that this guy lost his kid like
like it's just i know
i know so anyway um
when i think about winning dude i don't
think about though
i don't think about stuff
[Music]
i think about crushing people
okay i got a huge chip on my shoulder
nobody's ever asked me about it but it's
massive
my ship is like that big
okay so tell me about it man why is that
chip so big
i don't know why don't that it doesn't
matter it served me so well that i'm
you know you're just good with it yeah
i'm like let's roll you know
well because there's there's stallone
told me this too
uh interviewed stallone in california up
in san mateo
he's like got grant you got to have you
got got to have an adversary
he's like you look like one of those
guys it's like
he's like dude you're aggressive i said
bro you're rambo
right
[Laughter]
he's not he's like not really really i'm
rocky
so so he's like my dark side's rambo got
it
i said my lighter side is rambo
right on he's like he's like hey you got
to have an adversary
he's like arnold arnold he's like if it
wasn't for arnold grant i probably would
not be wearing that
like arnold was not a friend arnold was
a total adversary
got it repeated for roles people
compared us
you know so i've had a lot of that in my
career hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five have empathy with oprah
winfrey
i know you all understand better than
most that real progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being honesty and
above all
empathy i have to say that the single
most
important lesson i learned in 25 years
talking
every single day to people was that
there is a common denominator in our
human
experience most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview
is we want to be validated we want to be
understood
i've done over 35 000
interviews in my career and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way
asks this question was that okay
i heard it from president bush i heard
it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from
victims and perpetrators of crimes i
even heard it from beyonce and all of
her beyonces
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says
was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every
argument in every encounter every
exchange
i will tell you they all want to know
one thing was that okay
did you hear me do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people
you may disagree with
[Applause]
[Music]
that you'll have the the
courage to look them in the eye and hear
their point of view
and help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose our ability to stand in
somebody else's shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people
this is imperative for you as an
individual
and for our success as a nation rule
number six
adapt and overcome with jack ma when you
do business
my rule is never be feared never worry
about a competition never worry about um
you know the the pressures
if you worry about the pressure you will
worry about a competition if you're
worried about this
don't do don't be a businessman and
today the good thing is the whole world
worries everywhere people worry about
data people worry about privacy people
worry about security
people worry about you know anything
that normally is that means
great opportunity comes because you know
you cannot
stop this the internet time is coming
mobile time is coming back data is
coming you cannot stop
not worry with the only thing is you
embrace you change yourself
and start to do it and is there any
system
no if you have a system you never worry
nobody has a system asking a president
he doesn't have a system
right if you're a human being your
worries your doubts
but the only difference when you doubt
you will you fix the problem
you change yourself you fight again
tomorrow and rule number seven the last
one before a very special bonus clip
is have fun with jeff bezos one of the
first times that i read that i demoed
recommendations live um with a live
website i was speaking to
a group of wall street analysts
and and my number one recommendation
number one personal recommendation was a
dvd called
slave girls beyond infinity
and which was this is much less
embarrassing and you never know what
you're going to get i never know exactly
what i'm going to get because it is live
and
it does change you know from minute to
minute but i'm glad to see that today
i've gotten
you know apollo
and then i can see of course why was i
recommended this
because i bought cosmos and angle of
attack
and another book called apollo um so
uh but slave girls beyond infinity i'll
just show you was
was a little embarrassing
um what happened to that laser pointer
thing oh here it is
do not look directly into me okay um
there it is slave girls from beyond
infinity let's go over here
uh this is pretty interesting um it's
uh so you can buy this dvd with a salt
of the killer bimbos
buy together it's only 1996.
all of that product clustering is done
automatically of course it
the um you come down and you'll notice
that you know customers who bought slave
girls
also bought sorority babes in the slime
ball bolo rama
and my personal favorite cannibal women
in the avocado jungle of death
and there's this interesting thing here
we um we even
know when things are part of a series so
we say and also they bought dvds from
the barbarian queen
series so we can click through a quick
click through and look at the barbarian
queen and
um there's a customer review here
uh it says for lana clarkson fans only
this is barbarian queen
two this is not even barbarian queen
it's
an incredibly bad film whose only
redeeming feature is lena clarkson in
and out of some skimpy outfits she's
completely gorgeous but even she can't
save a disaster of a film
then here comes the great recommendation
buy death stalker instead
[Laughter]
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through
and when you share with other people it
jumps to 95
chance your likelihood of following
through and so i want that to be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you how
would you describe
each phase of the evolution of oracle
and how do you
uh sort of describe running each of
those phases
you got to do this quick i gotta
well i mean and clearly being a part of
a company with four people and being a
part of a company and by the way this
we're 85 000 now post
post merger with sun you know uh on 100
uh we think about
sun's got about 20 000 employees and you
know uh 25 000 employees we're about a
hundred and five thousand
uh so uh hundred five hundred ten
thousand we're not sure exactly
about that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed
what has not changed is i ran
engineering at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to
and i is always reported directly to me
as engineering not sales
not marketing not support and not
consulting not
services at various points in time lots
of other people have run
run those operations the back office
accounting
order management all of these things the
only thing that i've done
consistently during those 32 years is
run engineering because i believe
basically that once you reach you will
you know you'll win as as
as we say at oracle it's amazing our
good products seem to do very well
and our bad products not so well
so the thing i focused on and i think we
get the most most leverage
is developing the right products
recruiting the right engineers and
having the right organization
[Music]
if you want even more amazing advice
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there where's like we're trying to think
okay we don't make this at times like we
don't love this product but we think
others will love it you know that's not
really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either